shanxi and the ten rings brought dragons
to the marvel cinematic universe and
left people wanting more whether they're
androids or demons from the moon these
dragons fascinate as friends foes or
both these are the biggest dragons from
marvel comics that we want to see in the
mcu
finn fang fume is one of the most
enduring monsters in the marvel universe
created by stan lee and jack kirby in
1961's strange tales number 89 he was
later incorporated into marvel
continuity and is a cross media
superstar appearing in comics cartoons
and video games finn fang fume is so
familiar to marvel fans that the glimpse
of a massive underwater dragon in the
shanghai trailers led to wild
speculation that we now know didn't pay
off finn fang fume is an alien from the
far-off world of kakarothara and when
he's introduced lies dormant in an
underground temple a scholar familiar
with finfun's legend awakens him hoping
to turn him against the invading forces
of communist china leading to a wall
whipping ship-smashing chase worthy of
looney tunes at its most chaotic finn
fang boom's history in the marvel
universe almost defies description he's
fought iron man squirrel girl and thanks
to an inter-company crossover the
justice league of america he's converted
to buddhism been a chef and lived on
monster isle he's even saved christmas
all that's left for this enduring comic
book character is a long overdue
appearance in the marvel cinematic
universe
ask any marvel fan which classic
fantastic four villains they want to see
in the mcu and odds are they'll name
heavy hitters like dr doom and galactus
but if the mcu wants to introduce an ffo
never before seen on screen why not dig
a little deeper into the rose gallery
why not introduce
dragon man joining finn fang fume in the
very exclusive dragon in the little
purple pants club dragon man first
appeared in 1965's fantastic four number
35 an android created by professor
gregson gilbert and brought to life by
the evil alchemist diablo dragon man was
unleashed on the fantastic four during
their visit to state university he was a
creature of powerful strength and
rudimentary intelligence until in true
king kong fashion a beautiful blonde
sue storm soothed the savage beast
brawling his way across the marvel
universe he spot spider-man the hulk and
even the pint-sized heroes of power pack
but after sue and reed's daughter
valeria richards upgraded his
programming he became a valued member of
the future foundation
i was a force in the cosmos before the
worlds were made i have brought whole
civilizations low but do you really
expect to stand against the dragon of
the moon
so boasted the eldritch horror
imprisoned on titan in the new defenders
number 138 the dragon of the moon is a
demon whose corrosive influence can
compel others to do evil deeds to give
an idea of its power it once claimed
thanos as one of its disciples when the
youngest sci talent heather douglas
trained on titan to unlock her mental
abilities the dragon attempted to take
over her mind believing she had defeated
it heather assumed the name moondragon
as a symbol of pride in actuality the
dragon of the moon was slowly corrupting
her years later it successfully turned
moon dragon against the defenders
unleashing a threat that only ended
after several of her teammates
sacrificed their lives with its ability
to corrupt the seemingly incorruptible
the dragon of the moon would be a
terrifying villain in the mcu one
possible path toward the mcu is
surprisingly clear in the comics heather
douglas is the daughter of traxx the
destroyer and a member of the guardians
of the galaxy in her own right if
moondragon joins the on-screen guardians
can the dragon of the moon be lurking
far behind
unlike the other marvel dragons on this
list xiaolao the undying has technically
already appeared in the mcu if you count
a single pair of red eyes glowing in the
dark introduced in marvel premiere
number 16 xiao lao is an ancient dragon
who dwells in the mystical city of
kunlun and is the power source behind
the iron fist mythos a warrior must
defeat xiaolao the undying whose molten
heart is hidden inside a sacred cavern
if they are to absorb his power and
become iron fist included in this heroic
lineage is the modern day iron fist
danny rent but when the 2017 iron fist
television show on netflix welcomed rand
and kunlun into the mcu xiaolao was
nowhere to be seen though he was
mentioned by name xiaolao never made a
full appearance due to one disappointing
factor
the budget
as for danny rand himself finn jones
told a reporter in 2017 i'd love to have
the budget for these shows to have a
full-on game of thrones style dragon but
unfortunately you know we have budget
restraints that's the nature of the show
netflix's iron fist ended in 2018 after
two seasons but the character's rich
comic book history is still worth
exploring and xiaolao is still somewhere
out there in the darkness waiting for
his close-up superhero comics generally
make bad playgrounds for babies if
you're a baby in a superhero comic maybe
you'll be lucky like cable and be sent
into the future to become a grizzled
cybernetic warrior or you could be like
shogo lee and turn into a dragon
orphaned by a meteor crash and adopted
by x-men and former mall rat jubilee
shogo is a seemingly ordinary baby
having the x-men for godparents
automatically guaranteed shogo a life of
adventure but fate had a big surprise
for jubilee when she brought shogo
through a magical gate into the realm of
otherworld in excalibur volume four
number two fairy magic combined with the
unlimited power of a child's imagination
spontaneously turned shogo into a giant
fire-breathing dragon now the youngest
member of excalibur shogu acts as
transportation and defense for his
mother and their teammates while in
otherworld shogu the dragon would be an
adorable addition to the mcu but watch
out for those explosive tantrums
before the dawn of the superhero there
was
grog one of finfang fumes strange tales
fraternity brothers grog first appears
in strange tales number 83 as a member
of an ancient dragon race held back by
the great wall of china in the spirit of
creature features like gamera and the
deadly mantis the prehistoric beast
spends thousands of years sleeping
beneath polar ice until nuclear testing
behind the iron curtain startles him in
his second appearance grog boards a
soviet rocket ship destined for mars
seemingly ending his fire breathing
threat forever the 2005 comic marvel
monsters monsters on the prowl number
one revealed that grog had been seized
by the collector becoming part of his
macabre menagerie along with other
missing silverage comic book behemoths
like taboo and grodu though grog's city
smashing days were far from over
memorably played by benicio del toro the
collector is one of the most slippery
supporting characters in the marvel
cinematic universe the true depths of
his specimen collection are unknown
could grog be among them if nothing else
it would be fun to see grog and giant
man doing the mcu version of godzilla vs
kong
mr lao a once mortal man who gained
eternal life after a curse transformed
him into a lung dragon did the only
sensible thing with his immortality he
got a job acting as the advisor for the
atlas foundation mr lau utilized
centuries of experience to become a
master strategist with the added perk of
ritually devouring every atlas
foundation leader after the appointment
of their successor mr lau would
eventually grant his services to agent
of atlas jimmy wu though the only agenda
he truly follows is his own laos
machiavellian intelligence sets him
apart from the more bestial members of
this list and he would be an intriguing
addition to any upcoming mcu film or
television series plus after randall
park's scene stealing turn as agent
jimmy wu in ant-man and the wasp and one
division who wouldn't want to see him
trade quips with a colossal dragon
that's worth a try
flying past the finish line is the
x-men's diminutive dragon friend
lockheed debuting in uncanny x-men
number 166 by chris claremont and paul
smith lockheed is a member of the alien
race known as the flock with the x-men
trapped in space during the brood saga
lockheed rescued kitty pryde by torching
the brood aliens hunting her
accompanying the x-men back to earth
lockheed helped kitty fight off more
alien hatchlings and a beautiful
friendship was born given his small size
lockheed is often regarded as a pet but
he is highly intelligent and
communicates in several languages
including english apart from the x-men
he has worked with sword guarded the
time gem with the pet avengers and
squared off against fellow dragon finn
fangfun lockheed can usually be found
perched upon kitty's shoulder whether
they're dimension hopping with excalibur
in the crosstime caper or sailing the
high seas in marauders lockheed had a
cameo in the new mutants the final fox
x-men film alongside magic kitty's comic
book best friend but after the failure
of the new mutants at the box office it
would be a shame to consign lockheed to
cinematic limbo marvel studios plans for
the x-men remain unknown but if kitty
pride appears in the mcu as either the
wide-eyed junior x-men or the
swashbuckling captain kate lockheed is
sure to be flying by her side
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel comics characters
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one